this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host this is the ramsey show
dr
john deloney ramsey personality
best-selling author
host of the dr john deloney show which
is exploding as a podcast
and a youtube show is with me today is
my co-host open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight
eight two five five two two five sarah's
starting this hour off in charlotte
hi sarah how are you i'm great how are
you
better than i deserve what's up in your
world
um so i just wanted to ask um so my
husband are both full-time college
students
and we're going to be seniors in the
fall and i was just
wondering um whether or not you would
suggest we go ahead and pay off our
student loan
um with extra scholarship money that
we're expecting to be refunded to us
uh usually no uh your husband and you
changes the conversation a little bit
you're both going to be seniors in the
fall so you've got one year left
and how is the fall how's the last year
for both of you being paid for
all scholarships yeah so after we got
married we
qualified for more financial aid and so
the scholarship money that we had was
more than what it cost for tuition okay
how much more um for this
um upcoming school year we're expecting
about 13 000
per semester on top of your
yeah you're expecting how and how are
you eating
um well my husband works full-time as
well oh
okay cool very good and so what does he
make
i'm about 30. okay all right
um out of an abundance of caution no i
would just pile it up
and wait to wait to start your baby
steps until graduation
because both of you will graduate next
year
at this time and both of you hopefully
will embark on
much better careers than either one of
you have ever seen before agreed
so your pay should go up way up this
time next year
is that right right okay right at that
point i want you to have more than
anything added no more debt
if you have twenty six thousand dollars
laying around
and have no more debt and have two big
jobs and you start
your debt you start your baby steps
you're going to throw that 26
immediately at the student loans and the
only thing you will have lost
was how much you would have paid off
between or how much interest you would
have saved between
uh now and uh this time next year
and uh really you may not even be
accruing interest yet are you
no not yet well we did for all of our
student loans are from our
freshman year yeah um so we have
interest all the way up until
last year when they suspended that yeah
but but and it should go back on in
september so
uh i think that's when it comes back on
if i remember so you're gonna have a
little interest with my idea
but that's okay i would rather the big
thing is for sarah and her husband to
graduate with no more debt
and i want this cash as an insurance
policy to graduate with no more debt
then when you quote unquote start your
careers
following graduation one year from now
and you get the big jobs now we're gonna
really push
play on the baby steps get going hard on
it and we're gonna clean out any cash
we've got except a thousand dollars it's
not retirement money
we're going to throw it at your debts
which would obviously be your student
loans and or any other debts you have
don't take out any more debt
use this 26 000 to ensure that that
happens
that's the first goal it's kind of a
almost like the doctor's oath
hypocrite hippocratic oath do no harm
do no more harm is what this is don't
just don't allow yourself to go
further into debt and that's a cool
position to find yourself in that
suddenly um
scholarship money falls from the sky
yeah that's outstanding yeah well you
went and got it yeah that's good too
which a lot of people just kind of
wander along don't even bother
i mean if you quit going through school
like you take too much xanax then you
probably could
people just wander through like they're
in a haze and
in in her case to her credit they got
married went hey maybe there's some
oh let's go get some money i don't know
if i ever told you dave the number of
scholarship committees i sat on that
went un
spent because we didn't have any
applications for the money this is
internal scholarship money at the
university where i was an administrator
so how would they have found that money
we would announce please apply
so they should just know to go and apply
well donors will donate
right a million dollars and it rolls off
the interest out of the endowment so
there's a
thousand dollar scholarship here and we
would make announcement
after an announcement please apply for
the scholarship here's a list of them
where would they apply
they would go on the individual
committee no you'd go online to a
central place and write your
uh for any scholarships available
correct for
the university and it's there's not only
the university but your particular
college within the university right
and they just would sit there and say
well we can't we didn't have an
application for this one or this one or
this one or this one or
one savvy student would apply for all of
them and then we'd have to have the hard
cop do we give them all to one student
or
just let it sit there let it sit there
in a crew again right so just
like you said it's easy to put all your
eggs in that
scholarship basket as a freshman and
then you take your foot off the gas
man if you look every year man it never
seems well
anytime something changes like now we're
like old married people and we're
college students now that's a whole
bunch of scholarships which is what
happened with her
somebody donated money for marriage
students and
architecture program who fill in the
blank right phenomenal yeah phenomenal
zack is with us zach is in phoenix hi
zach how are you
hey i'm good thanks guys for taking my
call sure what's up
really appreciate it hey so i just need
some big picture wisdom from you guys
i i really want to pay off our house i
want to be completely debt free
and i have a rental property that
produces really really well
i've had this thought of selling that
rental property
taking the proceeds putting it on the
house which would still leave
a little less than probably a hundred
thousand dollars on the house to pay off
um i guess my big picture vision with
the rental property was to pay it off
on a 15-year fixed and then utilize that
to help cash flow my kids college and
other things
um but man i've got this desire to just
be you know completely debt free with
the house and everything but
i would love some input and some
perspective on what you would do
what's your household income
about 130. cool how do you babies
uh oldest is nine we've got a nine seven
five
three and one what do you owe on the
rental
uh 150 155 what's it worth
uh i would probably sell now for
probably around 280.
okay if you owed 1000
would you go borrow another 150 on your
house in order to buy this rental
if you didn't own it i would not
then it's time to sell it
okay a good rule of thumb on stuff is if
i wouldn't buy it again
it's time to get rid of it that includes
a boat
that includes you know just about any
material item certainly investments
and that keeps you from thinking about
too many other things so for whatever
reason
and i think in your case i can read your
mail because you told me what it says
the your reason is i'd rather be out of
debt than i would own this rental
but owning the rental is a good thing
but i'd rather be out of debt than
owning this rental
so how do i solve this dilemma when i
reverse engineered it on you you
instantly went
oh the debt thing's more important way
more important to me because you
instantly answered it
and so that you know for the same
reasons you wouldn't do this
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh how'd
you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you
make the most out of your budget visit
chministries.org
budget don't worry it's worth it
[Music]
welcome to the ramsey show dr john
delony ramsey personality is my co-host
today
open phones as we talk about your life
and your money
the dr john deloney show with new
episodes every monday
wednesday and friday on youtube eye
covers everything from anxiety to
boundary issues to crazy in-laws to just
wild mental health things it's a it's
really really
helpful and entertaining show it's a lot
of fun i listen to it all the time
not only because i'm the ceo and it's my
job to make sure stuff going out of here
is good but i just enjoy it
i appreciate that it's very good so be
sure you can tune in there if you'd like
to be on that show
you can call him at four six
nine three thirty two ninety one you can
email
and kelly and the team will get back to
you at ask john
ramsey solutions dot com ask john ramsey
solutions dot com
or you can talk to him right now triple
eight eight two five
five two two five diane is in california
hi diane how are you
oh i'm fantastic dave what a great time
to be able to talk to you thank you for
helping me
my pleasure how can we help well we've
owned our
boutique real estate and property
management business for over 40 years
i'm 68 my wife is 72 we're getting ready
to sell it to a
wonderful young man that i've trained
for the last six years
we've talked to a business broker
and he shared with us you take the
average
net profit for the last four years which
is 96 000
a year for us you multiply it on two
times
five two and a half times that gives us
240 000 and then we add back in our
discretionary
income and of 84 000
a year that gives us a value of 325.
my question dave is we're pulling out 7
000
a month from this business we're retired
pretty much we live four hours away from
the business
and i can't take that 325 and create
seven thousand dollars a month if i sell
it to this wonderful young man
so my question is am i missing something
i need uh your no you're not missing it
uh
but you know i i don't disagree with
your business broker much
uh the formula i use is a little bit
more simplistic now the 96 is that
after both of you uh women you're not
operating it today someone else is
operating it
yeah we have a a a broker manager
you're absentee owners you do no work in
the business
yeah right the only thing we do is do
about do a p
l statement every month on it yeah okay
well that would be as if i bought it i
would have someone run it for me right i
live in tennessee i'm not going to
day to day be involved in that so an an
investor
would buy it after all see when
sometimes sometimes when someone's
selling their own business they work in
the business
and we have to take their salary out of
the net profit too
what it would take to replace the
manager but in your case you've already
got a manager so we don't have to take
that out
so basically you're making a hundred
grand a year 96 a year
profit and i would say if the buyer
wants to make
25 on their money it is worth
four times that much if the buyer wants
to make
20 on their money it's worth five times
that much
so generally a small business goes in a
four to five
cap of net profits and so i'm a little
bit higher
than your broker but not much he's got
you at a high of about 400 with his ad
back
and um and my four times put you to
about 400
so that that is a fairly reasonable
valuation process that the business
broker used there
um he used 325 as well but he added back
the 85.
no the 325 the 325 includes the 85.
i think that's low the young yeah and
the young business broker we're paying
him
sixty thousand dollars a year as a
salary
to run it but you still after that
you're after that you're netting
96 after you paid him correct correct
okay so that that that business is
generating an
absentee investor 96 000
so let's call it a hundred thousand
dollars so if i bought it for 400
and i got 100 back i would be making 25
on my money you see how that works yes
yes and if i bought it for 500 i'd be
making
20 on my money okay
and you want to make over 20 buying a
small business because it's a higher
risk
investment than say a mutual fund that
might pay you 10 or 12 percent
so you know so usually a small business
is going to go in the 25
20 rates so i think it's worth north of
400 but uh
now how can he pay you let's go back to
that solving that
have you hired the business broker yet
are you are you obligated to that person
yet
we're not obligated per um legality
but per um he's the one who's been
running it
i trained him oh no no no who's who gave
you the valuation process
oh the business broker we have not
signed a contract nothing
okay so he just said this is how you do
it anybody okay good
because you're gonna sell it to your guy
is the goal
and you don't need a broker to do that
you already got your buyer
right but we don't he doesn't have any
money though
businesses yeah but no no no he doesn't
have any money
your guy that's running it is who you
want to sell it to right
right okay so you don't need a broker to
do that because you've already got your
buyer
that's true but we've never sold a
business before so
well you just need an attorney to help
you do the asset transaction is all
by california law that's and that's
nowhere near as much as paying a
business broker a commission for making
his sale
that he didn't make right he already
agreed to do it for five percent but
you're
a little stiff yeah because he didn't do
anything
except the transaction okay so you pay
an attorney to do the transaction
get get your business attorney talk to
them uh
about that now here's a way we can
structure it
what if uh the young man that is running
it
you're paying him 60 now
correct what if he agreed to say i'm
going to continue to
once i'm the owner i'm going to continue
to live on 60
and all profits in excess of that
go to uh the you guys the sellers
until we reach 400
then it would take him four it would
take him four years to pay you out
that's an idea some kind of an
installment sale like that but however
we thought
i think you can come up with the cash
but then the question comes back to you
i can't make on 400 even
i can't make 100 on my 400. that's right
yeah but you've got less risk and you're
out of the business why are you selling
it
if it's so great because we were old
no you're not
yeah no you're not uh 20 years from now
you'll be old
uh okay you know dave we had a good run
we've owned it for over 40 years
yeah and here's the thing you want a
little less risk and a little less
hassle
in the golden years exactly and so
you're going to make you're going to
make less return for that
exactly exactly so what can you make on
for
what can you make if you invest 400 you
can make about 40 a year
yeah yeah yeah and that and you're going
to get 40 a year but you're but it's a
lock
you got almost zero you got compared to
what you have now you've got almost zero
house on zero risk
and no more responsibility yeah yeah
that's that hassle factor
yeah yes you got it you you have to you
have to keep your finger on the pulse
of that and that requires muscle tension
in your hand
[Laughter]
and they got arthritis already
you guys are a hoot you all are fun
but dave because of you were debt free
yeah i didn't pay it off you did honey
y'all are awesome hey yeah go i i think
you accept
400 um and get work out of a deal with
the kid let him buy you out
and um and you're just going to make
less on your money
and the reason is is that you have less
risk and less hassle
yeah and you clarify today thanks a
million
thanks for calling in
that's how it's done i love it i don't
know when you were gonna enter that
conversation but i
i was that's my favorite spectator sport
right there
what a duo oh my gosh this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
in the lobby of ramsey solutions dan
and julia are with us from cleveland
ohio hey guys how are you
good good welcome welcome good to have
you how much debt have you guys paid off
forty nine thousand eight hundred and
four did you say twenty nine or forty
nine
four nine forty nine thousand eight
hundred four i'm gonna call that fifty
okay and uh how long did it take you to
pay off this fifty thousand
eighteen months good for you and your
range of income during that time
96 000 to 98 000. okay cool what do you
all do for a living
i'm a mechanical engineer i'm a
veterinary assistant
oh good very cool what kind of debt was
the 50k
had two car loans um some uh roof on the
house
and some credit card debt no student
loans no student loans we paid those off
already
okay all right so you're kind of bopping
along about normal
how long you guys been married 13 years
13 years
so after 13 after 11 years
all of a sudden this wasn't okay what
happened we were tired of living
paycheck to paycheck
and we were struggling to make ends meet
we actually got to a point where we
actually had to ask family for
money to pay the mortgage and that's
depressing
it was terrible so we actually our
friend
angie had told us about fpu and the
total money makeover book
and on one of our side gigs we actually
um
listened to the book and um
we realized that our our church was
offering the class
oh so you went to financial peace
university at your church yeah okay cool
we took the class
and we just ran with it wow okay so that
was the whole uh
you know obviously um
when the student is ready the teacher
will appear right yes and so
you walk into the class and boom it's
game on yeah so how far into the club
both of you were open to this we were
tired of it
both of us yeah just look at each other
we gotta do something absolutely okay
and so you walk into the class ready to
go
and was it first class game on or it
took a little while
first class was game on because we
actually had started a little bit before
you had told them makeover before that
yeah right we listened to the book
so we we had kind of started but not
really
fully into it the way that yeah you knew
how countercultural i was going to be it
didn't shock you
right exactly okay yeah you didn't have
to you got over the being weird part
before you got there okay very cool so
i'm i'm always interested in
my favorite part of these is is that
first conversation who came to who
how'd that go i think you came to me
right i think i came to you because
our my our friend angie was talking to
me about it okay
and then i had to talk to him so you got
the courage i had to talk to him so you
got the courage and she brought it up
and you said i'm i'm all in let's just
do something
yeah i just never really had a game plan
i don't think you know just kind of kept
going and doing my own thing and never
had any
you know real this is what we should do
so it wasn't so much as
you know it's just a lot of bad
decisions not knowing what to do
who was doing the bills both of us at
the time yeah
so you're you're talking about it
already but he just talked about how bad
it sucked
right exactly what was the dark night of
the soul
when one of you had to call the relative
oh
it was my grandpa and i
it really stunk yeah but
he was more than gracious and gave us
the loan and we actually paid it back
and it was very nice and said never
again never again
it's that feeling oh just the peace we
have now is just wonderful yeah
and even if he wasn't you know it
doesn't matter how gracious he is
because it still happens in your stomach
right yeah yeah that's dark night of the
soul that's a good way to say it
it's just when you have nowhere else to
go yeah visa won't even talk to you
right and you got to go to grand dad
wow yep yeah
didn't it yeah wow and you got to pay
that off during this time
yes yeah that's good yeah that's very
cool so what do you tell people the key
to getting out of debt is your
professionals you have done it
um say sticking to a budget you know
having a plan and
really sticking to it and being
intentional about where your money goes
and
just being making that important and
making an important part of your life
i think talking about it communication
we really i think we talk almost every
day about
our budget about money just how happy we
are where we are
it's nice that the conversations are
good now rather than you know
where's the money coming from it's like
all right now you know what can we do
yeah
it's a little less freak out now exactly
yeah i hear you yep
area so what's what how has this
improved your marriage
just the communication i would say and
not being stressed out about money and
being able to
really enjoy it rather than worry about
it
i you know i never i've never
contextualized it that way but there's a
difference between having a conversation
about what do we want to do versus
here's what we have to do
that's two totally different heart rates
when you're having that conversation
right
huh that's fantastic yeah one of them is
dreaming and the other one's
freaking it's treading water yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah that's cool that is a
different
different process well who are your
biggest cheerleaders outside the two of
you
our friend angie oh yeah good i'm loving
angie at this point
andrew's my head recruiter over there i
like her
and then our um our fpu coordinators
mike and tim
they were really yeah they kind of kept
with us throughout the process and we
were always emailing them saying hey we
did this you know they were all very
excited for us so
yeah helped us stay motivated wow very
cool
good job you don't get that from your
electrical engineer buddies who are
asking
why are you keep bringing your lunch man
exactly
definitely wow yeah and
you brought the kiddos with you what are
their names and ages let's get them in
the shot
we have emily who's nine and james who
is seven
all right so have they been practicing
are they involved in this
whole thing yes so they know about a
debt-free scream they know what happened
their lives have been changed because
their mom and dad took control
yes yes and i'm proud of y'all thank you
very very well done
we got a copy of the legacy journey
which is the next
step in your journey as you move on from
baby steps two and three and
really start to build some wealth and
increase your generosity i'm so proud of
you
very very well done and thank you to
your church for teaching financial peace
university it's a big deal
it's a very big deal very cool stuff
also a copy of the total money makeover
for you to give away
because the uh audiobook got you started
so now you can get somebody started with
a hard copy
so uh pay it forward a little bit good
good job guys
very well done yeah and don't ever lose
perspective that
you've set them up to not experience
what you guys did and that's legacy
that's reclaiming those
that those bad decisions from the past
and turning into the road that they can
walk on that's incredible yeah
good for complete family tree change
yeah all right it's dan
and julie emily and james
ready to go all right 50 000 dollars
paid off in 18
months making 96 to 98 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three
two one we're
[Music]
this is how it's done oh
man i love that that is so so cool
that's the coolest man you know
financial peace university
is a part of ramsey plus you hear it say
hear us talk about it all the time
your income's your greatest wealth
building tool when you get out of being
held hostage like that it changes
everything you can get out of debt you
can take back your income
you can get your marriage in a whole
different place different kinds of
conversations
where do you start financial peace
university is now part of what's called
ramsey plus
it's a membership and you get access to
all the tools including that class
to change your life forever with our
best-selling online courses
including financial peace university
listen this stuff actually works the
average debt paid off in the first 90
days
is dollars 5300. average person saves
twenty seven hundred dollars
that is an eight thousand dollar change
in position on average
in ninety days you can get out of debt
you can save you can free up your income
you can do it faster than ever
start with a free trial you can have
access to the class they took
at ramsey plus today text trial
to 33 789 that's trial
two three three seven eight
you know when i started teaching
financial peace university almost uh
25 years ago in a bad suit with an
overhead projector
and a hotel meeting room i had no idea
that it was going to end up on video
someday and that someday it would be on
the
internet internet and if someday a
family from ohio would get in their car
and drive to nashville
to stand on this stage in front of me
with their two kids and scream they were
debt-free
what a legacy you built man but pretty
cool for them i'm so proud of them
they're heroes
they are millions of families have
decided to take control of their own
destinies
i'm so proud of all of them awesome this
is very very cool
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225 kevin is in philadelphia hi
kevin how are you
hey dave good afternoon how are you
better than i deserve
what's up yeah i had a quick question me
my wife
the newly married we got married earlier
this year congratulations
thank you so much uh we recently just
paid off about 30 000
in student debt um so you know that is
so good good
uh but right now we're in steps four
five and six we also have the emergency
fund
um and we're wondering how much to
allocate to
retirement because we also plan to get a
house soon
in a couple years good for you all right
yep 24 she's 25. excellent way to go man
you gotta you got a game plan you're
rolling it out i'm proud of you
so some people we call that baby step 3b
you've probably heard that haven't you
yeah
so once you've got your emergency fund
in place that's when people start saving
for their first home
sometimes people also start saving for
retirement for
simultaneously and sometimes they put
off
baby step four a little while and put a
hundred percent of their savings into
the house fund until they so they get
there a little quicker
and delay starting their retirement fund
a little bit
either one is fine i don't want you to
delay starting it for 10 years
but delay starting it for one year or
two years is okay
if you put nothing in there so anywhere
from zero to fifteen percent
going into your retirement savings right
now
while you're on 3b is just fine does
that make sense
yes what's your household income
uh about 92 000. way to go wow and
so how much do you think you're going to
save uh so right now we have 27 000
saved
and then we have 10 grand in the second
account for the emergency fund
um and we're not sure exactly that was
my next question how much can i actually
afford
for a home so
based on the income and it's probably
going to increase
um you know maybe on average a little
bit every year
but we're wondering because we're
looking at homes now and maybe you have
some guidance
to how much we should be spending yeah
well run run some numbers with your real
estate agent or with an online
calculator out on a 15 year
fixed rate loan and you'll be at 275 3
somewhere in there right now on your
interest rate
uh and where your payment is no more
than one-fourth of your take-home pay
now take home pays after taxes not after
health insurance not after other
deductions from your
paycheck but just take taxes out of your
paycheck
and call that your take-home pay and and
then say
all right this is what we're going to
bring home and about a fourth of that on
a 15-year fixed
will keep you in a really really
affordable
uh uh situation in a safe situation
a safe yeah yeah you you'll have margin
to be able to do other things uh like
getting 15 going into your retirement
like when you have kids you can add
your uh emergency fund to that and um
and so on joel is in portland oregon hey
joel welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve how can i help
i know you're gonna say that i am very
predictable
yeah well that's a good thing
so i co-own a business with my
brother-in-law
and i bought into it a little over a
year and a half ago
and we we doubled the
business in the first year and we're
doubling it
in the second year as well but uh
he wants to sell his half of the company
and i'm just trying to
figure out what's the best way to go
about that
and if you think it's a good deal or
what i should
look out for
is there a personality issue do you all
not get along anymore is he just
is he setting you up
no we we work together uh fantastically
um
and uh both he and i agreed that we were
the only
people that we have ever wanted to do
business together
and uh it's been fantastic so far
he just does not enjoy the industry
uh that we're in and so he wants to do
something different he's
also a entrepreneur and he just wants to
try new things
and do something different try something
new
uh challenge himself and
so as an entrepreneur i totally get that
i support it um
so we're just trying to figure out the
best way to go about it
on uh on our end that's about a healthy
way to come at it i like it
so why do you why do you want to stay in
it
well i have uh almost four kids
and um and my wife and
i it's really important for
her to stay home with our kids and for
for us to raise them and so
there's that it's a good business we
make
we make a good amount of money we're
near our
family and we love our church and
it definitely has huge growth potential
and okay what was uh what was the net
what was the net profit uh in or what
will it be in 21 let's say
um if well
before taxes and expenses we're looking
to get
probably close to 350 to 400.
i'm sorry expenses are come out before
you make a profit
expenses we're probably
less than 40 000
maybe 50 000 in expenses okay taxes i'm
not worried about
i'm just saying i mean if the business
has business taxes that's fine we can
take those out
but what is the net profit that the two
of you will pay taxes on
you'll pay income tax on in 21.
uh probably about 350 000. okay
so 175 sure half 175 sis half is that is
it split 50 50
yeah okay and how how is he proposing to
be bought out and what does he want
he wants 144 000
over a four-year period
um so basically nine thousand a quarter
over four years
that's awful
for him or me for him what's going to
say man
that's where it's worth like 10 times
that
yeah that's not enough
um are you sure you're making what you
think you're making
ah yes why does he want such a small
percentage of this company
um that's a good question
i mean i think part of it is where
or family so you know i'll give you
another proposal
i'll give you another let me give you
another proposal okay wait a minute did
you guys take
salaries out of that before you got to
3.50
you made no money so you you're both
working you're both working there
and doing what what do you do there
so we the way we have broken down is
like we have a very small
salary check how much uh that goes into
our accounts every month and then we do
how much dividend check once a month i
know how much
like 2700 bucks okay so if i bought this
business from you guys and both of you
were gone what would i have to pay
managers to replace the two of you
to do what you do
well we're both out in the field as well
so
quick answer quick answer you're running
out of time
okay how much we probably
to be worth it for someone probably
probably about four to five thousand a
month
okay let's call it sixty grand let's
call it a hundred grand
all right let's take a hundred thousand
dollars to replace each 100
60 each
yeah okay so let's call it 150 off of
350 that's a 200
000 profit now his 144 doesn't sound so
bad
because his half is one hundred thousand
um
i suggest you pay him uh two hundred
thousand over two years a hundred
thousand a year for two years
and buy him out in cash you got plenty
of profit to do that with
and you still make a great living you
preserve your relationship with your
brother yeah
i pay him a hundred thousand dollars a
year for two years
and be done that'd be a good deal for
you
this is the ramsey show
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode of the
podcast show notes section
or head to the ramsay show.com thanks
for listening
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice i'm dave ramsey your
host dr john deloney ramsey personality
is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight
eight two five five two
two five danny is gonna start off this
hour
in harrisonburg virginia hi danny how
are you
hi gentlemen i'm doing great i'm a
little star struck
uh dave i gotta say i've i've listened
to you for years and
started when i took financial peace
university and um
my buddies give me a hard time but
whenever we go out to get a bite or
something say i don't know is that papa
dave approved
no that's cold
[Laughter]
well we're honored to have you sir how
can we help today
all right so the condensed version i'm
wondering if i should buy a house
that i do not want so a little back
story
my wife and i have been looking for a
house for the past year um
financially we're doing we feel prepared
as much as we can be we're in
uh baby step four we have a good chunk
of change set down
there is just no inventory in our area
and i finally broke today when i got a
call that a house we put a really
competitive offer on
um it went uh above it went
uh no inspection it went guaranteed
their
their offer price um and so just feeling
frustrated so i don't know if
we should just keep waiting uh our
landlord is selling our
the house we live right now and so we're
gonna be um
kicked out in august so we're a little
worried you know do we
find a place to rent and pay more than
what a mortgage would be or do we settle
on a
on a townhome or something really small
that we just don't like
i just went through this yeah yeah i
know
so what's the answer no no what don't
buy a house you don't like
yeah don't do that because you're gonna
wake up in
12 months or 24 months 12 hours 12 yeah
12.
i don't like this house oh wait i never
liked this house what the heck did i do
and you're going to it's like trying to
date somebody that you know you
have a future with and you just think
i'm going to i'll change them i'll
change them
that bathroom's not gonna move in that
house it's still gonna be there it is
yeah
i hate this for you hey listen i just
went through this it was
brutal it's a frustrating experience in
the market right now
and it really really is so this is euros
first home
correct and you're how old
uh i'm 28 my wife's 25. every time
i face something like this i read a
study like
gosh it probably 20 years ago and
it affects them affected my
decision-making paradigm ever since
here's what the study said
it said that people who build wealth and
become wealthy
make decisions based on how it's going
to affect
them 10 20 30 years from now
people who are broke make decisions
based on how it's going to feel this
weekend
yeah thank god it's friday oh god it's
monday
is we're broke it's what broke people
say but rich people when they get ready
to buy a watch
they say can i wear this for 10 years
20 years can i get some or when they get
ready to buy
they buy high they buy expensive things
sometimes but they buy high
value things that last that's right poor
people buy
uh and broke people and i've been both
but broke people buy
stuff that looks good right now but
that's cheap as crap and falls apart
you know and so it's kind of the same
decision-making they thank god it's
friday oh god it's money i'm gonna blow
all my money on the weekend
because i'm a child and so uh
emotionally
so the way i back up on something like
you're looking at when i'm frustrated
and tired
and feel boxed out by the market
which is all the things you feel and
it's your first house and ah man we're
going to pay more in rent we're going to
move twice because i got to go rent
something then i'll find something right
after i rent something and
all that then then you know i you know
so what what this tells you when i i pan
back i go what's the best decision ten
years from now
don't buy a house you don't like and man
it's hard
especially with my wife saying i just i
want to i need a home yeah right we got
two little kids running around
yeah um it's real real hard to be
patient yeah
talk to your landlord and go hey if i
pay you a couple hundred dollars more a
month
would you rent for me for six more
months yeah buy yourself a little time
that's right and um or go somewhere for
a weekend
just go on a quick little getaway do
something just to kind of clear the deck
wipe the
white erase the whiteboard and you gotta
start over again this is the worst
possible time to feel like you're forced
in to buy something right
because the market's called bananas
meaning people have gone bananas
they're nuts yeah i mean they're like
running down the street and driving a
stake in the yard this one's mine you
know
it's crazy the way they're acting and
it's just a freaking house
yeah i mean you can get you another one
there's one on every corner
uh but no don't don't settle don't cheap
out
because if you buy some kind of crappy
something because that's what's
available in this market
you know what it's going to be when you
get ready to sell it something that's
crappy
that's available in a hard to sell
market yeah
that's you're going to get stuck well
and beyond that you tell me when you buy
an
ugly house at a deal you know what it is
when you get ready to sell it an ugly
house and a deal
well and you tell yourself all these
these fantasies like
we'll just move those bathrooms we'll
build an add-on garage and get a
new roof none of that will happen and
you set yourself up for
so much disappointment when you're there
it's such a good discussion
though and that's why we're leaning on a
little bit and giving giving a little
bit more time because there's so much
activity in the market
so many people are feeling this listen
if you feel like
you're you're the temperature on your
forehead is changing
that's called house fever it's back away
you know you need to go take a cold
shower
back away from the contract
you know you're about to overpay you're
about to buy something you're about to
settle for something you don't like
and that's everybody out there man
you're just you're just an example of
everybody that's walking around looking
at houses right now
uh the opportunity to overpay is
legitimate and yes moving
twice but you know
let me tell you 10 years from now you
won't even remember no you won't or
you'll remember how bad it was
but 10 years later who cares yeah we
rented a house we sold our house after
bankruptcy
our kids were in these private schools
we moved to another county to get in
better schools and we rented
the first time i'd ever rented since i'd
owned okay and i
owned a thousand pieces of property by
then and gone broke right
now i'm a renter that kitchen in that
rental house it was a nice it was a big
old house it was a reasonably nice house
it was a great school system which was
with the whole goal right and we cashed
out of our other house and cleared up
the rest of the last of our debt after
bankruptcy
paid off the stinking irs right but
to this day when i mentioned that street
name
my wife's face gets a cloud across it
and all she says
is that kitchen that kitchen that
kitchen
that nasty brown linoleum floor that
kitchen
that kitchen because i mean she hated
hey but she transferred to that house
she transferred
that husband to that kitchen so that's
actually good for you
that's that's good we broke and we were
in that ketchup that's right that's
right
you're right she hates the completion
instead of dating she kept kept the
ire on the correct item yes that's good
but
i mean that's 30 years ago man it hangs
with you and i've bought a house
under pressure and i still did this day
of regret that i did that it's still an
ugly i put my family through it and i
bought an ugly house
it was still an ugly house when i got
ready to sell it i've done that i've
done it don't do it just take your time
brother
i know it's hard take a cold shower take
your time this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at 825-5225
alex is in cleveland hi alex how are you
i'm good guys good to talk to you you
too what's up so
i am 22 years old i just graduated from
michigan state uh with a mechanical
engineering degree
i am a contract engineer right now so i
i travel a lot
my question for you guys is i i've got a
girlfriend back at home
and she's still in school but uh
i'm i'm trying to save up for a house
for us and a marriage
and i'm wondering how to balance
my relationship with her while also
always traveling and always trying to
save up for
the next goal and i feel like i'm
at some points doing one more than i'm i
i'm uh
focusing on the other one and so i'm
i guess how do i put put my life in the
balance where
uh i'm enjoying my time with her and
seeing her
and should i move home where's home
find a closer job uh my home is
technically out of grand rapids michigan
and you're in cleveland ohio and you
travel what kind of range do you travel
uh so i i'm on my way to york um
stopped at a service station to talk to
you guys uh
but uh i i i traveled to pennsylvania
i've traveled to
kansas city um so three or four hundred
mile radius
yeah all right and you make what
i make 160 000 a year how long you been
out of school doing this
uh since january okay wow
that's not bad so man you're 22 years
old
and what i would tell most 22 year olds
who are not married or untethered is to
hit the gas on their
career this is a time you can stack up
and do really great
and there's so much technology that you
can stay connected to each other right
now that even i didn't have when i was
young and trying to figure this thing
out the question is whether is this
going to be seasonal for you is this
going to be the rest of your life
and that's a hard question you have to
ask and then the other question is it
sounds like you took this job and you
are making
unbelievable money for a 22 year old
and you're starting to not like it am i
am i hearing that right
yeah i i i love the money
um but i i i
want to be sometimes i want to be close
being on the road sucks today that's
right yeah
and here's what i don't want you to do i
don't want you to use your girlfriend
or your relationship to your girlfriend
as
the reason to cash out on this job if
you realize i'm on the road all the time
and that's not good for me it's not good
it's not the life i want to live
then i want you to own that decision
because other you're going to run into
money challenges down the road you're
going to run into relationship issues
down the road
and then you're going to start resenting
her for something that really isn't her
fault you don't like the job you don't
like the job
right and it's a million billion dollars
for a 22 year
old um but yeah if the road sucks and
it's killing you the road suction is
killing you gotta do something else
sure sure so how old how old is she what
is she in school
yeah she's uh studying to be an
elementary teacher
when graduate win yeah she's got a year
left
uh and then she has to do an unpaid year
uh through uh
internships uh at job site
okay does this job you're in you says
contract does it have an end
you're you cut off you cut out try again
it's contract do you have an end on your
job
um no they keep extending the contract
which is fine by me
um how long does the contract run
about as good as yourself on the service
okay um
all right so what i what i would say is
um
for 160 000 a year if you want to see
her you can buy a lot of airline tickets
um and uh you know
you fly over there and see her on
weekends or whatever and you work this
out you're making plenty of money spend
some money on travel spend some money on
connectivity
and then just set a date certain because
you're not going to do this for 10 years
right
inside a date certain are you going to
do this until she graduates and gets
through her one year or just until she
graduates
when are we getting married and you
start setting in your mind anyway
and you start going okay i can endure
this for two years and pile up a huge
pile of cash
or i can endure this until christmas or
i can endure this until whatever i think
the
i think the idea that it projects
indefinitely into the future
is part of what's driving you nuts but
um
and the road is hard right the road is
hard it is not
travel is only glamorous for people that
don't do it
and it's just not it's just you know
it's just a hotel so
god and uh yeah and if he's flying it's
even worse because you got to deal with
the dead gum airport people
so i like the idea of coming up with a
dollar amount here's what i'd like to
have
that's not bad and here i also like this
idea a date certain or a dollar certain
and then i'm out and i'm going to use
this as an opportunity to learn from all
these different bosses and all
these different cities use this as
graduate school man and if you approach
it with that heart and spirit i'm going
to work my butt off i'm going to make
this kind of money and
i'm going to learn from what i like
about this guy what i like then you can
set yourself up to what you want to do
but if you just look at it as misery or
if you blame her
slash no you can't encourage her uh then
man you're just setting yourself up i
had to quit this because of balance with
my girlfriend oh bullcrap you acquitted
because you hated your job i like the
job
i own that man that's what he's saying
but don't blame your girlfriends so
yeah but i uh yeah i think you've got a
two-year window
something like that and um and i like to
hey i like to see 22 23-year-olds
grinding i really do
yeah it's awesome there's nothing and
making that kind of bank
for a short period of time and again so
spence get it get a date or a dollar
certain
uh figure out what you're gonna do when
you leave this job
and uh uh thirdly allocate some money
for travel
for uh to see her or her to see you and
uh buy some airline tickets
or whatever it is and um you can land
this plane no pun intended with
a hundred thousand dollars in cash in a
bank or more 125 thousand dollars right
when she finishes up her
internship and then y'all can pretty
much do what you want to do
more because they're probably covering
the road costs too
greg's in raleigh north carolina hey
greg welcome to the ramsey show
hey how are you sir better than i
deserve how can i help
um i've got a question for you uh my
mother
is 93 years old uh just had to put her
into
assisted living a few months ago she had
with dementia
and we tried the home care option and it
got to the point where she was needing
24 hour care
yeah um she's in a good place my father
was
you know he's a past but he was very
smart with money he did the long-term
care insurance and it's helped a lot
wow my question is aside from you know
visiting her and trying to make the best
quality of life for her
what to do with her home uh she's bought
a
paid she got a paid for home about three
miles away from me
it's probably worth around 300 in a way
i wanted to sit back and just you know
process issues under assisted living for
maybe
two months on the other hand i've got
people around me saying
if you're gonna do it sell it now uh
don't wait
and uh i want to do what honors her
and how how cognizant
is she of this decision how much is she
able to process it with you
not um i would say no it's not
okay so this is just your it's just your
decision it's not gonna it's not gonna
bother her because she's not gonna
understand
no no okay so what do you wanna do
i don't know i wanna do i wanna honor
her and that's my biggest problem i
don't want to be a landlord i know that
yeah i don't know that keeping the house
is a method of honoring her or selling
the house as a method of honor yeah
you've backed yourself into a corner
that's not real
that's not a real that's not honor has
nothing to do with this house
unless you were hurting her by selling
it okay
or keeping it and you're not so
not emotionally not financially not
anything and so
um you i don't want to be a landlord um
i think it's just letting go of the past
to sell it emotionally and that's very
hard but i would sell it i would too
all right and now's the time to do that
am i right oh yeah for sure
yeah for sure get it dolled up get a get
a good go to daveramsey.com or
ramseysolutions.com and click on
elp for ram for endorsed local provider
for a real estate agent in the area
they'll help you max it out this is not
a time to play amateur hour
you need a pro in your corner and
they'll help you this from this
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just thirty dollars a month get
unlimited talk text and
six gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over seventy
dollars a month
by switching to pure top just go to
feartalk.com
and enter the promo code ramsey to save
50
off your first month puretalk simply
smarter wireless
[Music]
so
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage
bryce and lisa are with us hey guys how
are you
doing good dad how you doing welcome
where you guys live
we're from wichita kansas ah welcome to
nashville and all the way here to do a
debt free scream i love the t-shirts
i'm the nerd i'm the free spirit so we
know who we're addressing here
it's very clear up front very cool how
much debt did you guys pay off
370 000 in five years whoa
and your range of income during that
time we started at 67
000 and finished at 167. wow what do
y'all do for a living
i'm a registered nurse and i'm a captain
in the army wow thank you for your
service
appreciate your support sir thus wichita
okay
so i'm going to guess and say that might
have been your house
it was looking at weird people
yeah we need the subtext on the t-shirt
weird people yeah
are on the back when you turn around
yeah way to go man
wow paid for how old are you guys we're
32.
i have the paid for house you are truly
weird that is awesome guys you won
touchdown i love it what's this house
worth
uh last time we checked it was right
around 300 000.
how does that feel at 32 freaking years
old and i
paid for house it's outstanding dave
feels great
it's amazing congratulations it's a
whole different place to be
wow i got to hear this story what
inspired you to do this five years ago
so dave actually uh it started about
seven years ago where where
i married my wife and i took the
responsibility of being a husband
to heart and i wanted to lead my family
and
you know i ran across you on youtube
being a finance major in college i
gravitated towards the money aspect of
it
ran across you on youtube uh you know i
got all inspired i was working late one
evening and i binge watched a bunch of
your videos
and i came home all excited and i blew
it
i told i did everything you say not to
do i told lisa we were going to get
extra jobs we're going to not spend any
money
and we got to beat gazelle intense and
she's like i don't even know what that
means
and uh what does that mean yeah so you
need to stay off the caffeine when
you're working overnight
that's that's exactly right so um you
know so it took a couple years
your name was kind of a cuss word in the
in the johnson household for a few a few
years but
uh five years ago the beginning of our
story is when we when lisa informed me
that our daughter milo was
coming so all of a sudden her tone
changed a little bit she brought me to
the kitchen table
and she goes you know we should really
kind of look at our money situation and
uh you know i think we should take fpu
and i was like that's a great idea
wow wonderful now that it's your idea
it's awesome absolutely yeah it's a baby
step
it was and again my fault i totally uh
barged into it but
learn from my mistake everybody you go i
love it way to go
so um so you signed up for financial
peace university what a local church or
we did in fargo north dakota originally
that's where we're from originally
and uh we did went to a local church
there with a friend paige and zach
and we took fpu and from there we were
rolling in the same direction
and our communication improved and our
marriage just
went to new levels so lisa after you
were abused
with the dave ramsey stuff ahead of time
then
baby's on the way so you go okay
grown-up time i got to get serious
and you come into the table so i'm going
to do this was that hard to say
i want to put those words out of your
mouth let's
go to financial measures it was very
hard i wasn't ready to be weird yet
ah okay so when you went to class how
long before you started going
i think we might really should do all
this i mean really i mean you started
kind of buying in
like first class or eighth class or it
was it was the end of the class by the
time i was like all right i think we can
do this and right after
milo was born he was actually deployed
and that's where
um i really realized the sacrifice he
was making for the family and i was like
okay i better get on board a little bit
more with this oh wow and that's where
we really hit gazelle
and dave i gotta say too she was a total
trooper while i was deployed so she
as a nurse with a newborn baby with me
gone she was working night shifts
weekend shifts
wow she was still she was all in at that
and totally or totally bought in at that
point
and uh our grandparents that her
grandmother's grandparents um
helped with taking care of her during
overnight shifts wow things of that so
lisa just was a total trooper she jumped
right on wow
way to go you guys but the net result is
no payments
in the world i'm trying i'm sitting here
trying to figure out what was harder for
you to
eat a small amount of crow and say let's
take fpu
or for you the military commander
to be told what to do and you say yes
ma'am i'm all in
right i don't know which one had it hard
it doesn't matter right it doesn't
matter
and hey by the way you you guys didn't
just get out of debt you guys set out
from the beginning we're going all the
way with this thing
all the way jo we we we took dave baby
step seven the same way we did baby step
two we just kept our foot on the gas
okay
um and we said we're not going to do our
debt free scream until we were 100
complete
and what what kept that motivation going
for your three year four year five
i think the well biggest motivation was
us dreaming together okay uh once she
was on board
she all of a sudden at the kitchen at
the dinner table we were talking about
it every night you know what what
happens when we pay the car off
uh how about when we pay the credit card
off when we get our emergency fund how
good is that going to feel knowing that
every speed bump in the road is just a
speed bump it's not an emergency
that was my that was my aspect of it my
perspective
so you you took data and tied it to
emotion and tied that emotion back to
data and you just kept working and
working and working and working
kept dreaming for what was next i love
it i love it
yeah lisa uh uh not counting each other
who were your all's biggest cheerleaders
um we had some friends and family and
not a lot of us knew about the journey
we were on but they were
supporting us even though they didn't
know it helping us watch myla
um just in any way they could so we
could to
get it done yeah an fpu class had to be
going yay raw
oh absolutely yeah we actually uh so
five years later i emailed our fpu
coordinator back in fargo after we moved
around the country a few times
and he emailed me right back and said
that was amazing he gets emails all the
time from previous classes on how they
succeed and how much they've paid off
and everything so we actually coordinate
an fbu class at
reliance community church in wichita
kansas wow thank you oh
yeah and it was great we had some great
couples attend that and
uh we all got to know each other and and
experience a little life together so
very nice so myla must be five she's
four and a half four and a half
okay and you brought her with you yeah
and i love the t-shirt
check this out oh myla is the why
i'm the why you're gonna get me all
teared up on a monday
wow i'm the nerd i'm the free spirit and
i'm the why
i'm why my parents did this to change
our family tree
you guys are absolute rock stars i am so
proud of you that is such a
beautiful thing to meet hero couples
like this
every day this is incredible i
appreciate the encouragement
just to me and my family personally
inside and outside of this adventure is
extraordinary
thank you absolutely very very well done
so awesome well we've got a copy of the
legacy journey because you have
definitely poured on a new legacy here
and uh copy the total money makeover for
you to give away and encourage somebody
else with it so
very very well done you guys so
beautiful
so beautiful and she's cute as a button
too very fun
all right bryce and lisa and mila
wichita
kansas by way of fargo 370
000 paid off that would be the mortgage
and everything we're looking at weird
people
they did it in five years making 67 to
167
including deployment including lots of
nursing
ot well done you guys very well done
you're free you'll be able to do
anything you want to do 32
years it's you won guys i killed the
better man i already won the super bowl
i love it all right count it down let's
hear a debt free scream
three two one
that's how it's done right there
man that's inspiring i don't get to see
a lot of smiling families on my show
dave this is incredible
just incredible you get some of the
smile after you
told them how to straighten things out
man
you cannot be driving in your car right
now listening to this and still have an
excuse left
you can't you really can't i mean it's
ridiculous you can't
you're you're either gonna you're either
gonna be on the sidelines or you're
gonna be in the game you're gonna decide
them in or out
yeah you gotta get the game you gotta do
this i mean they're 32
years old and they were deployed and
working night shifts and had a newborn
and had to talk to parents and had to
figure it out and figure it out and
figure it out
and they looked up and five years later
they don't owe anybody
no excuses none no whining solid
get her done i love it man
what a crew this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
jacob is in knoxville hi jacob how are
you
[Music]
doing well how are you dave better than
i deserve what's up
uh so i am on baby step four and have 25
000 in my emergency fund
i'm 29 i make 130 000 a year
and i have a side hustle that i'm going
to talk about here in a second but
i currently have 54 000 in my 401k
and i put in 12 my company matches
4 and also puts in an additional four
whether i contribute anything or not
great uh and so the 401k has like has
awesome mutual funds i'm very happy with
them
um and so the situation isn't like to
get to my question
uh i started doing a dave ramsey-ish
last summer
i thought i could i'm in sales so i
always thought i could kind of out
out earn my dumb decisions so i never
got super intense until recently
but what i did do then it back then when
i started uh
listening was start a side hustle so
since last
july my side hustle has earned me 156
000 wow not bad and for
yeah and it should well outperform that
um next year i got a product i created
um into like 400 some source so
it's doing really well and so my
question my question
is around retirement funds so
i know you always say that uh do 401k
first then raw and then traditional to
get to the 15
and um but i cannot
contribute to a roth making over 139
000. i know you can do a back door raw
but since i like the way my 401k is
invested
i was wondering if it's better just to
stick with the 401k
instead of worrying about doing a
backdoor roth or if it still makes sense
to
well if you can get to 15 you putting in
15 of your household income
are you married i have a fiance
okay you're not married not yet okay so
no you make what at your day job
uh 130. okay you told me that six times
i'm sorry and then you made 156 on the
side gig
yes yeah so um you know that that puts
us at 280 000
that you need to save 15 of
okay you can't do that in just a 401k
you can't get there
because you're maxed out at night you're
maxed out at 19 and some change
and so you're going to max out your 401k
you're going to max out your roth ira
and you're still not going to be there
and so you what you're going to do is
you're going to sit down with a smart
vester pro in your area
and um and they're going to talk to you
on their side gig do you have any
employees
i do not so you can do a cell phone you
can do a sep over there and that'll get
us up
and you can do all of these in roths
okay so you're gonna do a back door
you're gonna do a sep
and you're gonna do a 401k all in roth
and you're gonna take your match over at
your company all they'll give you and
whether
you know all the match they'll give you
over there you're gonna max out every
bit of this in order to get to 15
of your household income going into
retirement now if your side hustle ever
goes away
obviously you're going to reduce what
you're putting in because each year
you're going to put in 15
of your household income but the sep the
sep roth is the way to go over
on your side hustle so it's a very easy
way to do it with no employees now if
you've got employees it starts to get
really complicated to pay in the butt
but um so go to ramseysolutions.com and
click on the smart vester pro click on
smart vester and get a smart vista pro
in your area to sit down with and let
them walk you through
doing the back door roth and you'll do
your own max out on your 401k and then
they can also walk you through setting
up a setup
a simplified employee pension plan okay
let's say what's what's a set
and it's you can do up to uh uh
13.2 i think so formula actually ends up
working out but
a large percentage of your net profit on
your business you basically create a
pension plan for yourself
exactly it's another it's a little it's
a 401k for a single operator
okay all right is what it amounts to if
you have employees
that have been with you more than two of
the last five years uh you have to put
the same percentage of their income in
so it's not very good for a small
business that has employees okay for a
solopreneur like this
it's very good excellent excellent for
doing that and i actually did one
with this business when i started it was
just me wow and then the uh
you know once i had been open uh five
years
then i had employees that had been with
me more than two of the last five i
truncated that puppy and okay went to
different direction on
retirement savings but uh that's the way
it went dave is in virginia beach hi
dave welcome to the ramsey show
hey guys thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
i am a 15 uh 51 year old single no kids
i'm feeling stuck in a rut and wondering
how to get better traction
the job looks stable for let's say the
next three years
looks real solid with the contract
income is about 69 000. we got about 12
000 in checking
a rut on what what kind of rut yeah what
do you wrote a career right a
psychological run
a relationship right it's pretty much a
financial
rut okay
and let's see 401k i've only got about
62 000.
oh 10 500 on a car
and 45 000 on the house where do you
want to be
where do you want to be with your money
i just really i'm
almost having anxiety about getting out
of debt yeah
why as quickly as possible you mean
you're having anxiety that's telling you
to get out of debt or
to not to get out get out of debt to get
out of debt okay so the debt is
bothering you that's good anxiety okay
yeah i mean i guess it is good it's an
alarm telling your house is on fire and
it is
right yeah you're right so you have a
ten thousand dollar car debt what other
debt
house 45 whatever um house
uh that's it but i do have some upcoming
uh remodeling expenses like a new roof
and a few other things i'm thinking
that's gonna be about sixteen thousand
what do you mean off on it till uh
sixty nine thousand without overtime i
make more when there's overtime
available what do you do
i do design work computer design okay
cool good for you
she got side hustle available to you if
you wanted to as well
all right and so let me get this
straight 55 000 plus
16 for the rehab
uh would be like 75 000
we'll call it all right changes your
whole life
it lets you breathe and it lets you
sleep right
now your house is paid off your car's
paid off and your house is rehabbed you
don't have a payment in the stinking
world you make 70 grand a year it
changes your life doesn't it
yeah so we need seventy five thousand
dollars you're a single guy making 51
oh there's 51 that's making 70. if i
need 75
that's 35 a year for two years
that's overtime on top of overtime
hitting the gas having some fun
not much how's this working knowing i'm
working towards the goal
oh yeah totally yeah that's the end goal
is fun but right now for two years you
don't have a life
you do beans and rice rice and beans and
all you do is work
and you become completely debt free with
your house rehabbed
and you're 53. i'm already feeling
better
in that contract you're worried about
going away in four years
that that contract you're worried about
going away in forty four years
it doesn't you're debt-free right yeah
yeah
that's a good point and if you don't
have any payments in the world could you
actually start doing some investing and
become wealthy answers yes
yeah absolutely i know that and when
you're not so anxious and knotted up and
tied up could you go hang out with some
other people get connected to a
community have some fun yes
yeah yeah probably so not probably 100
percent
yeah yeah you're right you need to do
that but that's why we call it financial
peace
two words that don't go together like
fouchy math
right okay so
all right so 35 000 a year for two years
yeah you can do it and i'll help you i'm
going to send you a copy of the book the
total money makeover it's going to show
you exactly how to do this
step by step okay oh awesome dave i
appreciate that big time
you hang on kelly i'll pick up we'll get
you going call us back when you're
debt-free and tell us
about your journey i want to hear your
success story you can do this man yes
i think you just need a little bit of a
clear path and uh
you're the man you're gonna get her done
baby
that puts this hour of the rims he's
showing the books good good hour john
thank you dr john bologna james charles
is our producer kelly daniel is our
associate producer and phone screener
i'm dave ramsey your host and we'll be
back
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you can have money and a career you are
the hero
in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solution broadcasting
from the dollar cart rental studios it's
the ramsey show where that is dumb cash
is king and the paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status
symbol of choice i'm dave ramsey your
host dr john dolone ramsey personality
host
of the dr john dolone show is my co-host
today
on his show he talks about anxiety
mental health issues of all kinds
boundaries relationship
questions so we certainly will weave
those
in between the retirement questions
today like they fit or something but we
will anyway
and open phones at triple eight eight
two i'm pretty anxious about retirement
dave
two five yeah we'll find out what
anxiety is when it comes to retirement
or something like that but hey if you
wanna talk to john this is your day to
do it or
or you can call his show at 844-693-3291
and have a chance to have your question
featured on the show or you can email in
at askjohn ramseysolutions.com to start
off this hour
lisa is with us lisa is in saginaw
michigan hi lisa how are you
hi hi how can we help
my mom passed away a little less than a
month ago
oh my i'm sorry thank you
i have um five siblings
one is diagnosed paranoid schizophrenic
and then i have two that are pushing to
sell my mom's house
right away and two that want to hold on
to it for a few months to
let it sink in and they don't want to
rush it
getting rid of stuff and and they're
both sides are putting me in the middle
and i don't know what the right thing to
do is i'm sorry
is there a will
yeah but who will just state that when
she passes
that you know the house will be sold and
it goes um it's split between us
yeah okay but it doesn't say you know
who is the executor of the will
my my sister that wants to hold on to it
till
for you know a couple months at least or
and then
my brother that lives out of town once i
hold on to it for a couple months
because he wants to come back in the
summer
[Music]
my one sister she's saying she wants to
sell it while it's hot market and
my other brother wants to
have a think about selling it to his
stepdaughter which
i already know that answer is right off
the bat no way right
i'm so sure i mean his wife couldn't
even come to the funeral so i'm not
letting it go to her family yeah i'm
sorry
how old are you guys what's the range on
your siblings
youngest and i'm 51. and the oldest day
now we're losing lisa lisa are you there
yeah okay you cut out the oldest the
oldest is one
oldest is what 64. okay 64.
i'm going to give you i'm going to give
you the answer and then john can fill in
the cracks
uh from the emotional standpoint as well
the answer is
it's not up to you
you don't have any say in this and
neither do your other brothers and
sisters
the will is very explicit and very clear
the executor of the will they are called
executors because the word means
execute they are to execute
the will what the person's will was what
the person desired
that passed away your mom's will gate
named an executor and told them to sell
the house
that is what will occur and it's not
up to you and it's not up to your other
brothers and sisters they don't get a
vote
this is not a democracy they don't get a
say
and so the executor is being wise
and saying we're going to wait a couple
months and let this kind of calm down
let folks have time to come in and pick
up an item out of the home for
nostalgia purposes let people have a
little bit of room to execute
the market's not going to cool off in
two months
it's okay that's kind of what my first
impression was okay
but it's not up to you the other one
starts pushing and pushing the other one
the other one's pushing because they're
broke and they want the money
yeah that's the only reason they're
pushing but they don't have a vote
so i think your job is to encourage your
sibling who is the executor
to do what the will says
and do it with wisdom and grace and
kindness
and that's all their job is nobody gets
to decide anything except the executor
by the way the executor doesn't even get
to decide anything their
job is not to decide their job is to do
what it says to do
it's to carry out to execute to carry
out
does that make sense yes and that takes
a lot of pressure
and a lot of emotion off of everybody
once all of you
understand you don't have a vote that's
right
there's a a unique role somebody can
step up and play
dave's right the will says here's what's
gonna happen to that house and here's
who's gonna make that decision
so that's that's written somebody can
step up and that might be you
and say this has been determined
and the person who will make this final
decision is the executor
all we can do is choose to support her
or to tear this family apart and i for
one
refuse to tear this family apart over a
couple of months
over some nonsense and everybody grieves
differently
i grieve by trying to go solve
everything other people i care about
grieve by just wanting to sit and absorb
everybody does that differently dave's
right one of them is going to be
one of your brother sister's going to be
broke and need the money the other one
wants it
for their family everyone's got these
ulterior motives but the end of the day
they're all grieving
and so if somebody steps up and says
enough
i've heard everybody's opinion i'm done
listening to you talk bad about my older
sister
i'm done listening to talk about why
your stepdaughter needs it
done i refuse to engage in this
conversation when she's ready to sell
this house
we'll engage in that conversation and
then you can call her and say i've
got your full support i i'm fully
supportive of how you want to do this
and um you want to put the house on the
market in two months i'm in full support
of that
and i'm i'm done with the conversation
period and you can send a strong message
through your brothers and sisters at
this type of
backbiting and um hurting each other
cutting each other we're done
it's over y'all can do it amongst
yourselves but you're not gonna include
me
and i will not hear it with my older
sister it's the the
difference in you getting the money now
or you're getting the money in two
months is not
worth destroying relationship with
everybody in the place that's right
and that's the message for the sister
that's or the sibling that's broke and
wants their money
and if the stepdaughter wants to buy it
and pay full market value
and go get their own mortgage and not
and just be a normal buyer they're more
than welcome
but to the extent that they get a
special deal the answer is no
right yeah i think he wants to give her
uh
a discount yeah i'm sure and that would
be the paranoid schizophrenic's daughter
right
no no okay
i was just guessing okay i missed all
right but uh yeah that's
you know this this is the stuff that how
fast this is how families play together
but john's exactly right just um just
throw your throw your hat in the ring
and support and just call everybody to
unity and love this is what mom would
want
mom would not want y'all all fighting
over two months we hear you want to sell
it now we're not gonna so stop
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
if you've ever made a dumb decision with
zeros on the end because you didn't have
the research done
well that would make you like most of us
me too
most people make choices based on
feelings or opinions especially when
buying a house
but when it comes to this real estate
market this is uh it's not an amateur
hour
feelings are uh not your friends facts
are your friends dr john dolany says
that all the time
so find out what you can actually afford
not what you like research
what's trending on home prices talk to a
real
high octane real estate agent in your
area to get the facts get with one of
our elps go to ramseysolutions.com
agent get an agent who will help you
make smart decisions because they have a
proven
track record of dealing with this market
ramsey solutions.com
agent our question today comes from
blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you mismeasure you miss you pick the
wrong color
you mess up they'll make your window
blinds over for free you get free
samples free shipping with the new
promos they run all the time
you save even more the promo code is
ramsey
all right today's question comes from
cassie in wisconsin
my husband and i recently decided to
move closer to family
but since making that decision my sense
of security is
crumbling we lost two businesses when
the pandemic started
we sold our house for a good price
however the area we are moving
to is more expensive we are completely
debt free but with the current economic
landscape i'm freaking out that we're
putting ourselves in a shaky position
how do we know that we haven't made a
huge mistake
hmm dave how do you tell somebody
to know if they haven't made a huge
mistake i kind of have a default answer
to that but before i just throw it out
there
i um
you know i it's not permanent
you can undo anything you're doing like
if you go there and it doesn't work out
you can leave
that's how do you know you haven't made
it so it's not a huge mistake you might
have made a mistake
yeah you might screw it up you don't
know but is is it life-threatening
no no is it going to ruin the rest of
your life financially
no not unless you stay there in the
middle of the huge mistake
but if you get over there and it's a
mistake then you leave
yeah um but um i can't tell what all's
going on here
uh if you sold everything and you lost
your business
and you don't have any incomes and
you're moving to an expensive area that
would be like
a good thing for you to be freaking out
because you don't have any income right
you should be freaking out uh but that
that's going to happen if you stay where
you are
you don't have any income so the lack of
income that i
think i'm reading here is um
you know you're debt-free but you don't
have income right you still have to make
money even when you're debt-free
and i read this more i'm i'm assuming
that they've got
they figured out they got to get jobs
i read this more as something that's
happened to me several times which is
i know what the right decision to make
is and i make that decision
and i still wake up in six months and
you get that
do we do the right thing and you just
feel like you're on unstable ground so
you got to circle back to again those
the data right the facts why did you do
this in the first place
is it the right move yes it is you
probably woke up and you don't have any
community anymore and you got to go make
friends again and you got to go figure
out
all those things that are not fun to do
but that slowly
help your feet settle into the to the
sidewalk right
well and you decide to move closer to
family and the great news is you're
closer to family the bad news is you're
closer to family
that's right but i might be sinking into
the fairyland view of being near her mom
might not be quite mom's nearer to you
oh my god but i've left
his jobs went somewhere new i knew all
the reasons why i left that job
and then dave whenever they finally
replaced me at that old position
i think oh for i don't know why it just
gets me a little bit and other the the
world keeps turning without me there
yeah you really realize you're it's not
yeah we can exist with that or old
employees call and say hey
that cool thing idea you had they just
changed it now they're doing something
else it's three four years ago
i still think oh man that was a good i i
suddenly realized
i had a little bit of my identity still
attached back there right well that
would be
human nature that's right and so i gotta
acknowledge it and then i gotta realize
i live here now and as you pointed out
how do you know it's not a mistake you
don't
so live into it make the best of it it's
an adventure you realize it's not great
move it's an adventure baby this is how
it works yeah
i think that's true and you're debt-free
you set yourself up for this kind of
move
right yeah there's a uh an old movie i
think it was called
parenthood with steve martin oh yeah
there's a bunch of one-liners in that
thing that are fabulous
uh but at the end of the i mean he goes
through all this turmoil with family
stuff
and it's just driving him crazy all this
anxiety all this angst and jobs and
loss and all this i i mean i don't even
remember what all it is but it's like a
constant the whole movie is a constant
state of crap
and at the end of it he's getting on a
roller coaster and he's right he's
riding the roller coaster
of life is the metaphor and he's
enjoying
the ride that's right with the ups and
the downs and it's a beautiful scene at
the end the beautiful metaphor for the
whole thing
because that is parenthood yeah yeah
it's gonna be you know that is moving
close to family that is changing cities
it's an adventure so
i it's still
let's say let's say you move um from
uh what the city you're in and you move
to the more expensive place
and two years from now you're miserable
uh
economically it's not working out
relationally it's not working out
and it we would if you want to call it a
huge mistake you can call it a huge
mistake
if you just want to call it a mistake we
could call it a mistake so two years
from now
what would you do what could you do uh
load up the truck and move back right or
go somewhere else
or start a third possible city right
that's the beauty of america it is still
as many
many people don't agree with this but it
is still free yeah and you can just
decide
i don't want to live in california
anymore right
and a whole bunch of people did and they
left oh man they did
yeah and i don't want to live in new
york anymore and a whole bunch of people
did
and they left right and uh
you know and i don't want to live near
my mother and you leave
right and i do want to live near my
mother so you go right
and you you know these are options you
can just decide and they could so the
cool thing about a decision is
if it's the wrong one make another one
yeah and
just because it's uncomfortable doesn't
mean you made the wrong decision
right and we see that with 100 of change
is going to be uncomfortable there you
go we see that with breakups with moves
with new jobs
they're always uncomfortable right and
we we often we're so obsessed with our
feelings
that we feel less than what we imagine
perfect is going to be we think oh we
screwed that up no you didn't
he didn't right it's going to be
uncomfortable for a season until you get
friends to get a community to get a
church
do you all find your date spot to you
find the place where everybody knows
your name whatever those are
and or two years you wake up and realize
this isn't the right move for us
yeah let's get out of here one of our
operating board members wrote wrote our
ramsey newsletter last week
and the whole opening thing was i hope
this week has been uncomfortable for you
yeah i hope this week you've had
conflict that was healthy
yeah i hope this week that you've been
pushed to be better i hope this week
you've been unde and the uncomfortable
conversation pushing someone else to be
better
i hope this week that you've gone
outside your comfort zone and it scared
the crap out of you
i hope this because otherwise you're not
living that's exactly right yeah
we are addicted to comfort in our
society yeah
addictive that's very very good stuff
very good stuff so hang in there cassie
hang in there
yeah make the move it's an adventure
ride the roller coaster do it
have at it and if it's bad just undo it
yeah just go back you're debt-free for a
reason i don't know if i should pay off
my house
i don't know i've got the money in my
checking account i don't know if i
should pay off my house
pay it off pay it off if you hate
being debt-free you can go get a
mortgage
people people don't do it but if you get
in there and you go you know this is the
dumbest thing i ever did
i hate being debt-free i can't stand it
i really enjoyed having that mortgage
payment
i want another one the mortgage company
will sign your butt right up
that's the beauty of america you'll be
right back in there in no time
if you pay off all your credit cards and
cut them all up and you don't you don't
uh like it they will give you another
one there'll be one in your mailbox
tuesday don't worry about it
you'll have another shot oh my gosh
i'll give a dead person and a dog a
credit card so definitely give you one
oh lord this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage
caleb and danielle are with us hey guys
how are you hey dave you're doing good
welcome where do you guys live indiana
princeton indiana
princeton near evansville evansville all
right
cool well good to have you guys thank
you and all the way to nashville to do a
debt-free scream
that's right and how much did you pay
off forty six thousand
five hundred eight hundred and fifty
seven so okay all right
very good and how long did this take uh
28 months
28 months and your range of income
during that time
60 to 80 000 cool good for you guys what
kind of debt was the 47
it was more more like uh normal stuff
like credit cards
medical bills car loans student loans
student loans being the biggest chunk
so you were just normal yeah a little
bit of everything just
bopping along how long y'all been
married uh since 2016.
okay so five years yes all right and
of that five years two and a half of it
almost
was spent getting out of debt so you
were married a little while and you look
up and go
this is no fun no so tell me the story
how did you get connected to us what was
your inspiration on this
um well a little back story we're coming
from different families of how we manage
money some of them just don't know how
to do it right some of them are just
organized and we just
came together as like a clump when we
got married we were like we don't want
to live in debt
i love plump that's what most people do
yeah we don't want to live
in debt so we were like okay what can we
do so we struggled along when we first
got married we're like we're going to
try and figure out how to pay it off we
just
got a credit card started using that for
a little bit um come in 2018 we
go to church and our church was holding
the financial piece
university oh there it is so we're like
hey let's just do this we'll try it
and i'm being the free spirit i'm like i
don't really want to be told where my
money goes and he's like
i got this so i was like okay we'll just
go through the class we did it
um a little bit probably it was in
november of 2018 in december of 2018
that's when we first started like let's
hit it hard we're going to start with
his student loans paid this car off
we cash flowed three cars during that
time we had a baby during that time
wow so it was just like let's get it
done um covet happened so they kind of
put a pause on it
yeah but we were well everyone was
spending it buying tvs and everything
we put it in what we call our own
emergency fund and called it the coved
fund so i wouldn't touch it
because i didn't want to spend it on tvs
or a new car or whatever
and that's what we used as my student
loans you've had a problem with tvs in
the past
tvs radios anything cool
i'm just trying to get that bigger size
tv now and then i always wanted
something bigger
yeah it's awesome so
we just finally just got to the point
where like let's just get it done i'm
tired of being in debt and i want to
change my family tree way to go so the
class gave you the framework
yeah and then you go through the
struggles of the ups and downs and the
kovids
and you push on through and knock it out
yeah how's it feel now that you did it
different it feels like a weight's been
lifted off that's for sure
yeah it's nice not having student loan
companies just hounding you for
uh monthly payments each time and
realizing being on the monthly minimum
payments that
you're hardly getting anywhere because
the interest is already catching up
almost
the exact amount we have extra money
we're like what do we do with it now
yeah you feel like you got a raise yeah
yeah you got control of your most
powerful wealth building tool now your
income
you guys are amazing way to go rock
stars how is your marriage different
we it worked on a lot of the
communication part of it it was more
like
i'd sit there and try to hide money from
them when we first got married like oh i
bought this and it's brand new and
where'd this go where'd this come from
and i was like okay so we just sat down
with like let's budget together let's
talk together we started talking more
and communication more we're able to
talk a lot better and we don't have the
fear of
oh no what did i buy and what is he
going to get mad at kind of thing we're
able to be like okay i can buy this okay
target bags under the bed
yeah oh my gosh in the closet yeah
hide in the trunk yeah yeah
that's powerful full disclosure there's
a clinton list to that
there really is there's a simplicity to
uh
having it all right there yeah and you
don't have any any side deals going
anything else it's it's really really
clean
good for you guys very good so your
financial piece and
university class cheer you on were they
cheerleaders for you they were
they were a big uh part of it we um went
through it again
just this like during covet just to try
and get a refresher and be like okay
let's keep going
good and uh the coordinator for it was
really proud of us when we
came to church and was like hey guess
what we paid it all off
oh it's awesome so yeah very good you
guys
very good so what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is now that
you've done it
i would have to say that sitting down
together and actually
discussing everything in regards to
where the money needs to go
actually writing it out and following it
you know basically making your own road
map and
working together to figure out where the
road bumps are that you got to start
planning for on the side as well as
keeping up with your regular
utilities and mortgage and everything
else and keep it visual so you can see
where your goals are going so you can
see what you're going to do so when you
start paying off your debt you can have
like a
pie chart in a way and color that off
okay we got there okay we got this and
then
just keep going that's good so
how do you encourage families with young
kids when they're in the middle of this
and a pandemic and homeschooling and
it's crazy but
just start it and once you start going
you'll you'll get to the momentum where
you like you see a change you see it and
you just keep going
i've heard a rumor that if you don't buy
your kids everything they want
they still manage to survive is that
true
apparently they're still standing there
right here
i get hated a lot every single day but
i'm like it's not in the budget
our four-year-old now she used to sit
there i used to say well it's dave
ramsey's fault
[Laughter]
so she started saying it's not in the
budget it's not the budget
anytime we talk about this this is why
this next generation doesn't like me
yeah but i can't wait till she starts
dating someday and looks at somebody and
says that's not in the budget
exactly you've wired it in at a young
age i love it yeah
where'd you get that money yeah
that's so perfect well well done you
guys we're very proud of you
excellent excellent job heroes man you
took control of your life you're debt
free 28 long months and you brought the
three kiddos with you what are their
names and ages
aidan is 10. uh presley is four and
ryman is
gonna be one gonna be one at the end of
the month oh wow okay
cool we've got a copy of the legacy
journey for you that's the next chapter
in your story to go
complete the uh changing of your family
tree
and of course the uh he's pulling mom's
hair that's great
and uh of course the total money
makeover for you to give away
as well so caleb and danielle aidan
presley and ryman they got their hands
full evansville indiana
47 000 paid off in 28 months making
60-80 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one
[Music]
yeah that's how it happens right there
oh that's seriously fun man that's
amazing
that's very well done you guys very well
done
i mean you got three littles that size
it's chaos
it is you know a day and what month what
year it is you're trying to homeschool
everybody and
still keeping that that goal in mind and
keeping enough
like that last shred of sanity to say
nope not in the budget we gotta keep
doing it we're gonna keep going
we got a bigger goal of sanity it's the
last boundary we
cannot cross it's not in the budget wow
so you remember uh a thousand years ago
before there was
much facebook there was a thing called
myspace yes
so the dave hater club goes all the way
back to
space there was a teenager group on
myspace
titled i hate dave ramsey and it was all
the teenagers whose parents were doing
our stuff
and they were told no it goes all the
way back those people are now 35 years
old
hey if you were a part of the i hate
dave ramsey myspace group
yeah and you're in your 30s please write
in kelly what happened let kelly know
yeah we'll we'll put you on we'll do
like a whole
i hate it i used to hate it maybe you
still do and now i'm debt-free
maybe you were trained at an early age
to hate dave ramsey and it stuck with
you
yeah well maybe your parents used me
like she did as an abusive tool that's
right as a woman dave ramsey saying it's
not in the budget it's dave ramsey's
fault that's what she said
it's dave ramsey's fault that's right
now i'm going to go out there and those
kids are going to hit me they are going
to break yes
that's what's going to happen her son is
eyeballing you right now he's like
oh that's fun well there's a lot of
things i get blamed for that i didn't do
but i did do that you did do that and
one day when she recognizes what
a changed family tree looks like and
just how different her childhood was
than her her friends in school she'll
say ah that day wasn't so bad
after all yeah my mother my mother she
said it's not in the budget i remember
my mother her mother's the hero
yes right that's it her dad's the hero
this is
the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today proverbs 11 24 and
25 one person gives
freely yet gains even more another
withholds
unduly but comes to poverty a generous
person will prosper
whoever refreshes others will be
refreshed
margaret thatcher said no one would
remember the good samaritan if he'd only
had good intentions
he had money as well yeah poor people
are generally not
fed by poor people starving children are
not fed by poor people
generally speaking that's how that works
so the ability to live like no one else
so that later you can live and give like
no one else is the highest
calling of money it's the highest
calling of this subject matter we deal
with around here
if you're a business owner or leader
listen up financial wellness
benefits are the thing now
in the wellness space you're no longer
really optional the team here at ramsey
solutions we just did a
survey a piece of research and found
that half of all
employers say their employees are
stressed about money
but only 18 percent feel responsible
for their employees financial well-being
well no one's responsible for someone
else's well-being as an adult
but you are responsible as an adult as a
business leader
to pour into your team money stress
if it's following your employees to work
every day it's killing your bottom line
and it creates turnover missed work lost
productivity
even possibly dangerous situations
because someone's not concentrating in a
manufacturing setting
you got to fix this if you're leading
out there get our team's report for
free and learn how to make it right
text wellness to 33 789
that's wellness 233789
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host
today uh huda is with us in winchester
virginia hi huda how are you
hi uh good evening thank you for taking
my call sure what's up
uh i'm going to start a new job in
august and they are offering me
a retirement retirement plan it's um
the hybrid retire retirement plan
this plan has two parts the first part
is the defined benefit plan and the
the other one is the defined
contribution plan i don't don't
understand how they work
it's my first time um uh
having a retirement plan i'm going to
work in the walking school system
okay all right well the defined benefit
plan uh you don't have any choices in
they're just gonna do it
uh the other is optional and i would not
do it i would do roth iras in good
mutual funds
before you invest in their retirement
plan
and if i decided to choose there what is
the difference between the
um uh between the roth ira are
um and the other one you have control of
what it is
invested in and it grows completely
tax-free
when you put it into a roth ira you
don't have any control in a defined
benefit plan of any kind
it is defined by someone else not you
thus the phrase
defined benefit plan uh it is a on the
benefit side it is a benefit meaning
they're giving it to you so
obviously we take money that's free
regardless of if it's poorly invested or
not
uh but not free money money that you
have to put in
a defined contribution that means you
contribute
no thank you i'm not going to put money
in something i don't have any control
over and is stuck there
when i leave so not really a good plan
i avoid those they're not the end of the
world but
it's not where i would put my money if i
woke up in your shoes
pretty simple megan is in san antonio hi
megan how are you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um so i i'm 44 years old and i've um
already saved a pretty good nest egg i
had a goal of saving a million dollars
in my retirement by the time of 40.
and i finally hit that at 44. where'd it
go
44 44 year old millionaires
yeah very very nice um
but my question is um i do still have a
car loan
and a home mortgage um and i'm starting
to think about
potentially investing in like rental
property
and i'm wondering do i need to you know
pay off my car
and my house before i start saving yes
okay
and then after that save to purchase
a rental property property with cash
excuse me sakulakali that's what i did
okay several hundred million dollars ago
that's what i did very nice i got out of
that after i went bankrupt started over
never borrowed again got our house paid
off used all of my income
to pile up and buying a rental property
then pilot and buy another rental
property then pile up and buy another
rental property and every time you have
a paid for rental property you know what
they make next year a lot of money
because there's no payments on them and
every time you have another one you can
buy another one even faster
it snowballs in your favor this time so
you are apparently making bank what do
you make
uh well i make 130 but i am one of those
people that have
i feel satisfaction from seeing money in
the bank so i started
saving early on um and i'm still putting
about 20
of my pay into my retirement i guess
that was my next question
i would temporarily stop that now that
you're a millionaire
uh you can't really use that money at
your age i'd temporarily stop that and
clean this car in this
house up uh do you have any uh you have
any emergency money at set aside at all
i've got my savings of around four grand
four thousand dollars is your tire is
your entire non-retirement savings
yeah you had a singular focus girlfriend
wow
wow you had a goal and you were pedaled
to the metal on
that goal i'm so proud of you though yes
it won't take long to clean up the other
you've got 130 000
income i would temporarily stop because
can you sense for just a second if i
just speak it
it hasn't happened yet but can you kind
of breathe in
what it's going to feel like to have no
car payment and then take another breath
would it feel like to have no house
payment
to go with your million dollars right
that'd be amazing yeah because it set
you up then to
go go to the next level on the wealth
building because here's the thing
oh man the numbers are astronomical yeah
here's the deal
your retirement i assume is invested in
good mutual funds
yes okay if you don't add to it at all
it will double roughly every seven years
okay so you're 44. did you hear that
voice yeah really
so you're 44 at 51 it's two
at 58 it's four at 65
it's eight if you add nothing to it
oh okay okay so that's why i'm okay with
you temporarily stopping for a moment
here
and knocking the house out okay so we
know that that's going to happen
in addition to that we also know you're
going to do some additional savings
because we can't stop you from doing it
it's how you're wired
that's a wonderful thing by the way so
if you do
additional saving and investing
including buying rental properties with
cash and so on
i would project that fairly
conservatively if my 8 million was
accurate on just the doubling right
is it fairly conservatively you're going
to have 20 million dollars when you get
to 65.
oh god we see this is what happens when
you hit this
this stage but now one component of that
is
you can invest even more you know i
throw money like when my house is paid
off i throw money in an
index fund just to pile it up to pay
cash for rental property okay
okay if you put it you save it in an
index yeah i just throw it into a mutual
fund until i have enough to buy a house
or buy property that
creates income okay okay and then you go
buy another one then you go buy another
one then you go buy another one
and of course every time as i said every
time you do that you've got that money
freed up
so you could sit there and put 20 into
retirement
and put your house payment plus
2 000 a month extra into this index fund
to buy rental property with pretty quick
and see now we've added a whole other
dimension to the 8 million because we're
back to saving 20 percent and that's how
gotcha that's what got you to a million
to start with
so you've done you've set yourself up if
you play this through
to go to the next level the first level
of wealth is one to five million dollar
net worth
you've blown that out of the water
because of your age you're gonna i mean
you really screw this up you're gonna
beat that up okay but
if you don't screw it up you're going to
go that next level which is deca
millionaire
10 million or more really and you really
if you'll focus just a little bit you're
going to be at 20 million
and megan will you do me a favor
will you have some fun
yeah i well it's hard like i have been
trying to travel more
and good good yeah money is for
generosity enjoy your life for fun
and for investing so that you can do
more generosity and more fun yes enjoy
your life too
that's all it's for there's only three
things you can do with it
john dolan incredible man what a neat
lady very powerful way to end the day
love it way to end this hour james
charles is our producer kelly daniels
our associate producer i'm dave ramsey
we'll be back before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you